en préparant ce toc
j'ai longuement réfléchi à comment je
pouvais éviter de de démarrer avec une
confession qui est un peu embarrassante
pour moi mais je n'ai pas trouvé
donc je me suis résolu à vous faire cet
aveu assez peu glorieux je n'ai
absolument aucune volonté
donc je suis incapable de tenir un
régime plus d'une demi journée 2-3 jours
dans mes périodes fastes
je préfère largement rester au chaud
sous ma couette plutôt que d'aller faire
du sport surtout quand il pleut
et alors j'ai une fâcheuse tendance à
remiser dans un coin de mon bureau tous
les documents administratifs qui
m'ennuie et pendant longtemps je me suis
dit que le problème c'était mon manque
de volonté et que si je n'y arrivais pas
c'était parce qu'il fallait que j'ai
plus de volonté donc je me suis employé
pendant longtemps à faire ça à
développer ma volonté
alors je prenais des résolutions et puis
j'essayais de me motiver à grands coups
de belles injonction bien punitive je me
disais des choses comme tu as pris deux
fois du dessert légumes à l'eau pendant
une semaine ou bien mais qu'est ce que
tu fais encore là sur le canapé à les
bouger les fesses ou encore amy tu
préfère aller au café plutôt que de
traiter des dossiers bravo belle preuve
de compétence honnêtement avec le recul
ça n'a jamais vraiment très très bien
fonctionné mais comme on m'avait dit
quand on veut on peut
je me disais que si je ne pouvais pas
c'est parce que je ne voulais pas assez
donc je persistais dans mon idée qu'il
fallait que je développe ma volonté que
je veuille encore plus et j'étais
entretenu dans cette croyance par le
fait que parfois j'arrivais à faire
illusion
je tenais un petit peu quelques jours
quelques semaines pas plus de quelques
minutes devant un bon petit plat
malheureusement
mais je finissais toujours par lâcher
prise laissé tomber et alors je me
vautre est dans la paresse et dans le
laisser-aller ce qui m'énervait beaucoup
et donc je repartais dans dans mon idée
de à nouveau me contraindre prendre des
résolutions et tout ça il ya quelque
chose que je n'avais pas très bien
compris à ce moment là et que je n'ai
compris que beaucoup plus tard et c'est
mon nouveau métier qui m'a permis de
comprendre ça il faut peut-être
d'ailleurs que je me présente un petit
peu plus donc je suis ingénieur insa et
dans une ancienne vie professionnelle
j'ai été responsable des achats dans des
entreprises industrielles et dans cette
visite professionnelle en tout cas
j'accompagne des gens à qui je permet de
dépasser des problématiques relationnel
ou émotionnelle qui peuvent rencontrer
aussi bien dans leur vie personnelle que
dans leur vie professionnelle et donc
chaque jour je rencontre des gens qui
sont coincés dans un mécanisme un peu
similaire à celui que je viens de vous
décrire
donc ils ont un problème il se fixe un
objectif
jusque là tout est normal ok parfois
l'objectif pour être discutable mais là
n'est pas le sujet bien il se fixe un
objectif et ils choisissent une façon de
s'y prendre pour résoudre ce problème
pour atteindre cet objectif là encore
tout va bien parce que la façon dont
nous avons nous y prendre pour résoudre
nos problèmes
elle est généralement logique pour nous
c'est celle que nous avons apprise c'est
celle que nous avons expérimenté à
d'autres occasions et qui a parfaitement
bien fonctionné et donc aucune raison de
ne pas retenter à nouveau donc nous
essayons cette façon là qui nous paraît
logique
et puis ça ne fonctionne pas alors
jusque là tout est normal parce que
personne ne réussit tout du premier coup
mais comme on a raté on réessaie normal
aussi mais ça ne marche toujours pas
alors on réessaie encore mais cette fois
on va faire mieux un peu plus fort un
peu plus dure un peu plus strictes un
peu plus haut
ça ne marche toujours pas alors on
réessaie encore à nouveau et puis encore
et puis encore et puis ça ne marche
toujours pas alors déjà
là si on prend un tout petit peu de
recul sur ce qui est en train de se
passer
je trouve que parfois notre façon nous y
prendre pour résoudre nos problèmes
notamment en comptant un peu trop sur
notre volonté est un petit peu absurde
parce que c'est un peu comme si nous
nous fixions un objectif ici et nous le
et sans rien changer à notre façon
de nous y prendre
nous imaginons que nous allons réussir
ça à part un miracle je vois pas trop
bien comment ça peut marcher
paul watzlawick qui est un des
fondateurs de la proche interactionnelle
et systémique de palo alto que j'utilise
et qui a écrit des bouquins extrêmement
intéressant sur la façon dont on peut
créer nous mêmes nos propres problèmes
paul watzlawick donc appelé sa faire
toujours plus de la même chose
une des difficultés c'est que comme je
l'expliquais c'est difficile de se
rendre compte qu'on est en train de
faire toujours plus de la même chose
pour une bonne raison c'est que on a
parfois un peu des illusions et on
interprète les choses de travers quand
je finissais par tout lâcher alors que
j'avais tenu bon pendant trois jours je
n'avais pas mangé de gâteau au chocolat
quand je finissais par lâcher donc
j'attribuais ça à mon manque de volonté
et j'avais l'illusion que si ma volonté
était plus forte j'allais pouvoir tenir
indéfiniment
en réalité ce n'était pas du tout ça le
problème
mon écroulement était la conséquence du
fait que j'avais fait tellement
d'efforts pour tenir bon
c'était la panne sèche plus d'énergie et
le fait d'avoir plus de volonté ne
m'aurait jamais conduit à résoudre ce
problème mais ne m'aurait conduit qu'à
plus d'écroulement plus tard encore plus
bas en réalité si je peux dire ça
autrement laisser tomber et
hypercontrôle autoritarisme et laxisme
ne sont pas des opposés ce sont les deux
faces de la même médaille
ils sont la con
séquence l'un de l'autre donc la
première difficulté qui se pose c'est
comment je me rends compte que je suis
en train de faire toujours plus de la
même chose
une des premières clés ce serait
peut-être je sais pas bien quelque chose
qu'il faudrait qu'on nous apprennent
depuis tout petit c'est que il n'ya pas
de bonne façon de faire quelque chose
qui ne fonctionne pas ok la deuxième
chose c'est que nous devrions apprendre
que nous avons un signal interne
extrêmement intéressant qui nous permet
de nous rendre compte que nous sommes en
train de nous obstiner pour rien et ce
signal
c'est la violence alors ce que j'appelle
la violence c'est vous savez cette envie
de secouer les gens de ce coup et
l'autre de un peu le punir un peu le
piquer un peu l'humilier pas parce que
nous aurions une espèce de drôles de
malveillance interne ou quelque chose de
méchant nous mais juste parce que nous
voulons le faire réagir
cette violence là elle n'est pas encore
une fois quelque chose d'anormal
c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement utile
et alors quand je parle de violence par
rapport à l'autre l'autre ça peut être
une partie de nous-mêmes
ok donc cette violence n'est pas quelque
chose d'anormal c'est une information
extrêmement importante est extrêmement
utile
elle montre d'abord que nous sommes
motivés
si nous n'étions pas motivé si notre
objectif n'était pas important pour nous
nous allons nous aurions laissé tomber
depuis longtemps la deuxième chose
qu'elle montre c'est justement que nous
sommes en train de nous épuiser à faire
quelque chose qui ne marche pas donc une
fois qu'on a appris à entendre ce signal
et à se dire quand j'en arrive là où là
il faut que je m'arrête et que je me
pose des questions que je prenne du
recul sur ce qui est en train de se
passer est bien la question qui vient
après c'est ok j'arrête
mais qu'est ce que je fais d'autres
comment je m'y prends
comme je les dis précédemment notre
façon de nous y prendre
elle nous est logique elle fait du sens
pour nous il paraît logique de se mettre
un peu des coups de pied aux fesses aux
fesses pour se motiver et parfois ça
marche mais l'idée c'est de savoir
s'arrêter quand ça ne marche pas faire
autrement
ça demande un peu de créativité changer
de façon de s'y prendre
ça demande effectivement de penser un
peu en dehors de nos habitudes mais ça
je pense le constate que nous sommes
tous capables de le faire
souvent quand tout va bien là où ça
coince c'est que souvent dans nos
relations aux autres et dans nos
relations à nous-mêmes changer de façon
de faire ça suppose de prendre des
risques de prendre un premier risque qui
est si vous changez de façon de faire et
que le problème se résout vous allez
être confrontés à une sensation
extrêmement désagréable qui est jusque
là je me suis mal conduit j'ai fait des
choses non seulement inefficace mais
inadapté
j'ai été un peu nul et ça n'est agréable
pour personne et donc c'est un des
premiers freins qu'on rencontre dans le
changement qui est mon image personnelle
souvent minimise ce frein là mais en
réalité il est assez important le
deuxième risque que nous devons prendre
si nous décidons de changer de façon de
faire c'est celui que le problème ne se
résolvent pas et que même en changeant
de façon de faire eh bien ça ne change
rien si on y réfléchit bien c'est un
risque que nous prenons déjà quand je
compte trop sur ma volonté pour résoudre
mon problème je ne fait qu'entretenir le
problème mais c'est un risque je n'ose
pas l'avouer je me dis va finir par
marcher si je décide consciemment de
changer de façon de faire je suis obligé
de me confronter aux risques ben ça ça
marchait pas et peut-être que ça ça va
pas marcher non plus donc je me dis
qu'un autre enseignement qui serait
intéressant à retenir ça serait aussi
que
parfois pour atteindre un but il faut
savoir l'abandonner alors moi par
exemple j'ai osé prendre quelques
risques assez petit il faut bien le
reconnaître mais quand même
déjà j'ai laissé tomber le quand on veut
on peut
et je les remplacer par quand j'ai envie
je peux je peux vous dire que quand j'ai
envie je peux vraiment beaucoup
et donc ça m'a conduit à plutôt que
d'essayer d'être strict avec moi de
tenir encore plus fort et tout ça de me
dire je peux pas décider d'avoir envie
mais du coup de me dire comment je peux
créer un contexte qui va rendre les
choses agréables pour moi plaisante où
je vais m'amuser et je me suis surprise
à faire des choses que j'aurais cru
impensable avant par exemple à faire mon
ménage
ok bien les gens que j'accompagne il ya
des gens qui prennent des risques encore
bien pire que les miens je pense par
exemple à cette dirigeante d'entreprise
qui avait tendance à rougir avancé prise
de parole en public et qui évidemment
était extrêmement embarrassés avec ça
elle elle a pris le risque de 1
l'assumer de parfois l'annoncé à
certaines personnes et aussi elle s'est
amusée à faire quelque chose d'un peu
loufoque qui est d'essayer de rougir
encore plus ce qui évidemment n'a pas
réussi à faire mais en faisant ça ça lui
a permis de réaliser qu'elles essayaient
de maîtriser la maîtrisable mais ce
n'est qu'en faisant cette expérience là
en prenant ce risque là qu'elle a réussi
à comprendre ça et elle a été beaucoup
plus à l'aise après ça je pense aussi à
ce manager qui était confrontée à un
collaborateur extrêmement critique qui
était émettait toujours des avis négatif
sur ce qui se passait sur les décisions
qui était prise et le pauvre manager
essayé en vain de recadrer son collègue
pour aller vers quelque chose de plus
positif de plus enthousiaste et bien ce
manager il a pris le risque d'encourager
les critiques et alors il a découvert
plusieurs choses la première c'est que
il a découvert que ses avis critique
était intéressant que ça lui permettait
lui se perfectionner voir les choses
autrement progresser il a découvert
aussi que son collaborateur pouvait
parfois dire des choses positives mais
qu'il était tellement focalisés sur le
négatif qui ne les entendait même plus
donc peut-être que ça serait intéressant
aussi de se dire qu'il faut qu'on
apprendra qu'on apprenne à prendre des
risques
ça me rappelle une interview que j'ai
entendu récemment de sarah blake lee qui
est la fondatrice de spank ce une grosse
entreprise américaine et elle racontait
que son père leur demandait souvent à
elle et à ses frères et soeurs ce qu'ils
avaient raté dans la journée et il était
extrêmement déçu s'il n'avait rien rater
parce que ça signifiait qu'il n'avait
rien essayer de nouveau donc si j'ai
envie de vous inciter à aller vers moins
de volonté si vous avez envie d'y aller
aussi je vous invite à retenir ces trois
choses là il n'ya pas de bonne façon de
faire quelque chose qui ne fonctionne
pas parfois pour atteindre un but il
faut savoir l'abandonner et je vous
invite aussi à vous demander comment
vous prendre vous prenez des risques et
donc je vais juste vous laisser repartir
avec cette question qu'est ce que vous
avez raté vous aujourd'hui
et qu'est ce que ça vous a appris